es geht um den hier unser bundeskanzler
olaf scholz gestartet mit ganz ganz
vielen
vorschusslorbeeren chef einer ampel
partei spd grüne und fdp und hat eine
zeitenwende ausgerufen ende februar nach
dem kreml diktator wladimir putin die
ukraine überfallen hat man muss sagen 18
wochen jetzt später stellte fest olaf
scholz hat aus dem kanzleramt eher ein
schneckenhaus gemacht er steht auf der
bremse und jetzt kommt sogar das
internationale us magazin time und
lästert über den bundeskanzler mächtig
ab die teamkollegin wirft olaf scholz
vor er zaudere zu lange auch der jüngste
beschluss endlich schwere waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern der sei nur zustande
gekommen aufgrund von internationalem
druck will sein olaf scholz der immer
wieder bremst bremst bremst seine worte
fressen muss und der am ende kein macher
ist doch das ist genau das was wir
brauchen im kanzleramt da darf kein
bremser sitzen da muss ein macher sitzen
in deutschland eine wichtige führung
nationen dieser welt und wer auf dauer
nein sagt der hat irgendwann gar nichts
mehr zu sagen das darf unserem land
nicht passieren
herr martenstein scholz er ist es
braucht ich kenne immer nicht also ich
meine ganz im ernst ich weiß nicht wofür
er steht ich weiß nicht was er will
bei merkel wusste man das so ansatzweise
ich habe das gefühl wir leben in so
einer fortsetzung der ära merkel nur
nicht so unterhaltsam wenn ich stolz
reden höre
werde ich immer sofort müde und
zum beispiel diese panzerlieferungen die
jetzt erfolgen sollen die gebhard panzer
für die scheint es ja nicht ausreichend
munition zu geben und es dauert auch
eine halbe ewigkeit bis man die leute
ausgebildet hat damit sie mit diesem
fenster was machen sollen ich weiß nicht
warum man da nicht gummibärchen die
statt jährlich also ich bin es gab ja
mal 5000 beliefert worden aber das war
auch ein witz also gummibärchen werden
wahrscheinlich dann die gewesen der hat
sich hätte vorstellen können ich bin ein
bisschen sarkastisch dass wenn manche
vielleicht unpassend finden aber dieses
hin und her
was die ukraine politik angeht und was
waffenlieferungen an geht das hat schon
was sehr unwürdiges finde ich diese
leute kämpfen um ihr leben kämpfen um
ihr land wir haben wirklich keine zeit
und wenn man ihnen nicht helfen will
dann soll man es begründen und dann soll
man es sagen dass man sich ihr kanzler
über den harald martenstein so spricht
das muss ihnen doch wahnsinnig weh tun
oder sie habe olaf scholz mit gewählt
also kann man das so stehen lassen was
harald martenstein sagt ja dass also das
ist so ankommt in der bevölkerung kann
man verstehen also er hat halt seine art
die dinge anzugehen für uns bei ihnen
auch so an
ich habe ihn jetzt so persönlich leider
noch nicht kennen lernen dürfen aber
ehrlich gesagt vermisse ich ihn auch ein
bisschen also ich bin halt ein typ ich
mag gerne führungspersönlichkeiten
jemand der da steht und klare
ja klar redet ist olaf scholz weil er
sich im kanzleramt einen bunker oder
dahin zurück zu vermissen eine starke
führungspersönlichkeit wo wo ich auch
das gefühl hätte okay er hat das im
griff und
der friedrich merz jetzt ihnen lieber
als kanzler in dieser situation
den kenne ich auch nicht persönlich also
ich mache es jetzt wirklich an
persönlichen sachen
fest ja also das problem ist wir hatten
halt keine gute auswahl sag ich jetzt
einfach mal so nah und wir haben
irgendwie mit unseren kanzlern immer so
eine komische sache gab dass schröder er
sozialdemokrat war fand ich schon
komisch hätte ich jetzt auch nicht
tippen können dass die märke
christdemokraten ist fand ich auch
passten nicht so und jetzt habe ich den
job ja ich würde durch märz auf jeden
fall für den besseren kanzler halten als
jahrhundert extrem herb los nein also
das ist aber natürlich ein wichtiger
punkt wir haben in deutschland in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten in vielen fragen
auch führungen an den tag gelegt das war
unter sozialdemokratischen kanzler so
dass wir auch unter christdemokratischen
kanzlern so immer auch in enger
zusammenarbeit mit anderen europäischen
nachbarstaaten auch mit kleineren
staaten das war zum beispiel kann zu
sein wie helmut kohl ganz wichtig und
dadurch hatte deutschland immer eine
ganz besondere rolle in europa im
positiven sinne jetzt haben wir diese
besondere rolle im negativen sinne weil
wir hinterher dackeln mit der ampel
koalition mit olaf scholz als
bundeskanzler weil entscheidungen
teilweise innerhalb von wenigen tagen
komplett wieder
verworfen werden man weiß nicht woran
ist man es gibt keine klare
kommunikationslinie und die anderen
staaten gerade kleinere länder wie
island wie liter und die gehen im moment
voran und irgendwann ist der druck so
groß auf olaf scholz dass er nachgeben
muss wir haben den druck ja auch in
dieser woche auf olaf scholz und die
ampel koalition entfacht beim thema
waffenlieferung aber wir brauchen
natürlich auf dauer eine bundesregierung
die aufführt und dirigiert und die nicht
nur aufgrund des öffentlichen drucks
reagiert sebastian geisler war das
erwartbar dass olaf scholz
sich so einmal zurückzieht auch in
seinem kanzleramt wie wir es gerade
sehen hätte es wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich erwarten können wenn man
sich einfach anschauen wie ist er denn
eigentlich kanzler geworden er hat sich
ja relativ passiv gegeben nach dem motto
wohnen nicht groß negativ auffallen im
wahlkampf und dann wird schon der spd
balken am tag der bundestagswahl war
irgendwie irgendwas über 20% land und
dann die union knapp übertrumpfen genau
das ist ja auch passiert nur er ist
jetzt eben ermahnt und er muss jetzt
tatsächlich führen und es musste ja
sogar offensichtlich so weit kommen dass
im ausland der eindruck entstanden ist
deutschland steht auf der falschen seite
der geschichte also so dramatisch im
grunde bis scholz sich bewegt hat und
jetzt endlich handelt und das ist
natürlich eine ein reputationsschaden
der deutschen außenpolitik das wird
möglicherweise jahrzehnte dauern das
wieder in ordnung zu gute so weist auch
nicht es ist ja auch nicht das erste mal
stichwort nord stream da haben wir das
vor einigen monaten und einigen wochen
erlebt da haben gerade die
sozialdemokraten in deutsch noch an
nordstream zwei festgehalten als
eigentlich alles schon gesagt haben also
die inbetriebnahme die kann nicht
erfolgen und jetzt haben wir das gleiche
bei den waffenlieferungen erlebt und
eben auch bei vielen anderen fragen und
wenn das so weitergeht dann ist
deutschland international wirklich
blamiert und dann wird es ganz ganz
lange dauern bis dieser reputation
schaden wieder behoben ist es denn so
also
sieht das ausland das so ihn als
schwarzen kanzler oder schätzt man
vielleicht eine souveränität dass er
sich nicht ausdenken und jetzt also ja
ob er das thema gesehen hat auch merkel
zur miss world gekürt also das haben wir
gesehen hat durchaus nach der bild
zeitung würde ich sagen
macht und power und kann auch gewisse
trends aufnehmen und möglicherweise auch
verstärken am abend stand sie haben mal
einer kolumne ja ein paar wochen her
olaf scholz angela merkel und helmut
schmidt miteinander verglichen zumindest
auch deren herkunft da silva beim thema
heimliche kanzler und hamburg und haben
gesagt offenbar lieben die deutschen
dass ein kanzler pragmatisch und spröde
ist ja
es ist ja auffällig dass von den kanzler
der letzten jahrzehnte schmidt der
einzige ist der noch ein positives image
hat bei den leuten und eine lichtgestalt
ist kohl hatte die spendenaffäre das
schwarze die schwarzen konten am bein
und brüssel den ehrenvorsitz abgeben
schröder naja da weiß man ja und bei
angela merkel ist natürlich die
reputation jetzt auch beschädigt durch
die falsche russlandpolitik durch die
zusammenbrechende infrastruktur dieses
landes durch die probleme der
bildungspolitik usw usw das erbe ist ja
zumindest sagen wir mal fragwürdig die
cdu kann das ja nicht offen sagen weil
bei jedem finger den sie in richtung
merkel streckt weisen ja 54 auf santa
punkt das heißt sie sagen die deutschen
wählen sich immer mal wieder oder am in
den vergangenen jahrzehnten sich den
falschen kanzler eigentlich gewählt na
ja wir haben nur mein demokratisches
system insofern kann man sich den
falschen kratz leid nicht wählen weil
ich meine der der es wird der der ist es
eben aber die sehnsucht
der leute ist glaube ich schon dass da
einer steht und
sagt was er denkt und was er will daran
kann man sich ja dann auch reiben
gegebenenfalls und das ist ja die große
stärke von scholz hauptrivalen das ist
natürlich der grüne haben der natürlich
mit großem rhetorischem gaben gesegnet
ist und dem man abnimmt dass er egal wie
man es findet auch wenn man es falsch
findet dass er das sagt was denn er
schon und auch seine gefühle zeigt das
ist natürlich eine art und weise von
politik die nicht nur bei mir sondern
bei vielen anderen leuten auch gut
ankommt ich bin wirklich kein fan dieser
partei aber ich bin ich habe großen
respekt davor wie habe ich das macht und
vor der folie habeck sieht scholz
natürlich nicht gut aus also mehr gefühl
in der politik ist glaube ehrlich das
wasser jährlich kite auch im jahr würde
man stolz unterstellen er ist nicht
ehrlich wird sich das unterstellen nein
das unterstelle ich ihm nicht aber
vielleicht ist er ist nicht offen das
bessere wort ja denn was er wirklich an
motiven hat für diesen eiertanz mit den
waffenlieferungen
das sagt er uns ja nicht er rückt ja
nicht damit raus warum er das erst nicht
wollte und er rückt auch nicht wirklich
damit heraus warum er dann doch mit
diesen 100 panzern an gedanke tca und er
lässt vor allem seinen worten endlich
taten vorher wir haben ja alle erlebte
der deutschen bundestag ende februar
diese historische debatte und seine
worte jetzt muss die zeitenwende kommen
und genau diese zeitenwende ist bis
heute nicht erfolgt wer die bundeswehr
hat immer noch mit großen problemen zu
kämpfen er hat seine eigene partei nicht
so richtig unter kontrolle da gibt es
jetzt schon diskussion es soll kein
militarismus geben der
fraktionsvorsitzende hat in dieser woche
noch davor gewarnt dass die ukraine mit
schweren waffen beliefert werden soll
dann hat er druck irgendwann gewirkt
jetzt haben wir das zum glück heute hier
im deutschen bundestag beschlossen aber
man merkt diese zeitenwende die es
einmal ausgesprochen worden ist ein
schönes wort aber das ist noch nicht in
politisches handeln umgemünzt worden und
wir brauchen jetzt führung gerade in
diesen zeiten schon vieles von dem was
gerade eben hier am tisch gesagt wurde
das treibt auch
die bild leserinnen und leser um die
zuschauer denn wir haben gefragt gestern
einmal wie müsste eigentlich der super
kanzler aussehen was für eigenschaften
müsste er mitbringen und herausgekommen
ist genau das hier wir sehen dass die
wir haben zehntausende ihre stimme
abgegeben dass 16 prozent der meinung
sind die wirtschaftskompetenz von
friedrich merz die muss ein kanzler
unbedingt haben das kann man glaube ich
ganz gut sehen hier an der neuen brille
von friedrich merz aber auch ganz
interessant die entschlossenheit ihrer
parteifreundin der fdp
verteidigungsexpertin genau marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann das ist die dame mit
dem grauen haar ganz entscheidend finden
16 prozent derjenigen die mitgemacht
haben für ganz ganz wichtig für einen
bundeskanzler dann sehen wir eloquenz
christian lindner 11 prozent sagen das
ist ganz ganz wichtig aber auch die
bodenständigkeit malu dreyer die
spd-regierungschefs von
rheinland-pfalz auch das wird als
wichtig angesehen und
schlagfertigkeit da sind wir bei dem
thema ein bisschen mehr gefühl sagen ein
bisschen mehr offenheit die
schlagfertigkeit von barbara
schöneberger
die wünsche nach zürich und jetzt muss
ich einmal selbst schauen wo ist denn
ihr barbara schöneberger irgendwo ist
hier auch barbara schöneberger drin das
ist selten partie sieht auch so aus also
meine damen und herren und hier auch in
der runde sieht sehen viele viele
deutsche den optimalen super kanzler
wir haben ob ich heute abend ein
bisschen was dazugelernt für jede partei
ganz alten straßen ein bisschen wie ein
bisschen wenig friedrich merz aber drin
dann können wir uns unserem perfekten
kanzler ja nicht packen also bis auf
eine chance geben also wenn wir jetzt
schon beim vergleich von kanzlern sind
so hat meine vorgängerin die ad hoc in
krisensituationen in meinen augen falsch
reagiert also das war die
migrationspolitik und fukushima so
einfach aus dem bauch raus und deswegen
bin ich schon froh dass er irgendwie
sich sammelt und ich hoffe nur dass er
aber wir können in diesem fall brauchen
wir jemand der führung zeigt und nicht
der sich noch lange sammeln muss